(upbeat music)
(audience cheers and claps)
- [Kelly] I love this whole look.
- Oh my God, thank you.
- Y'all Look like you're about
to make a real rad video.
I'm just saying right now.
- Yes, yes.
- Have you ever met Seal?
Have y'all ever met?
- No.
= No, we haven't had the pleasure.
- Well, now you have. You're welcome.
- So nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you too.
- Legend.
- Aw, thank you.
- So wait, we all made
it through the pandemic
and we weren't able to do live shows.
We weren't able to be out there.
That was kind of hard
for a lot of us artists.
But you're out there now, so
what's your favorite thing
since you've been back out on the road?
Favorite city, favorite
thing, favorite feeling?
- Just being with the
audience. A real audience.
I just did a Jingle Ball
iHeart Radio Arena tour.
I did all 10 shows in the
U.S. and it was so cool.
Just night after night, arena after arena
and just like feeling the crowd.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And not being home through Zoom.
And you know, even now with
everybody here, it's great.
- I know you forget like you feed off
that energy as a performer.
- Yeah.
- And we really got to
know that when you're like
all of a sudden doing like private shows
or any kind of show, like from a camera.
- Yes. It was just-
- [Kelly] Weird.
- It is weird. Because you're just like,
"okay, I am stuck at home".
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And how am I gonna connect?
- [Kelly] Yeah, absolutely.
And that's, it's a lot harder to do.
So what things do you have
to do before or after shows?
Do you have any like rituals or anything?
- Oh man, this is tough
because I do a lot of stuff
with a lot of people all the time.
But I always have Ava time carved out-
- [Kelly] Oh right before?
- on my schedule right before I perform.
- Yeah.
- So like, everyone's putting my wires on
and my mic pack and everything.
And then I have 15 minutes to myself
and I just kind of meditate.
Close my eyes and just like,
remember, you know, my
name, what I'm singing.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Stuff like that. (laughs)
- I literally have 15 minutes carved out
before I go on stage where
I have my alone time.
That's the same thing.
- Really? Isn't it the best though?
- Because everybody's always around you.
Even if you love them, you're just like
I just need a minute to
breathe before I get out there.
- Yes. And I'm the type
of person where I do like,
I really thrive through
the chaos. I love it.
I feel like my house
is in the sky sometimes
because I'm barely even home
in L.A., when I'm in L.A..
- [Kelly] Yeah. Seat three A. Yeah, yeah.
- So I'm actually more comfortable
on tour lately, which is weird, but-
- That's a young thing. That was me too.
- But I still need...
No, no, no, but I still need my Ava time.
- Absolutely.
- I still need that carved in.
- Do you have any like thing you have
to do before you go on stage or after?
- Just balance. I just try and stay-
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Focused and it varies.
Sometimes there are people,
I like people around.
Sometimes I like being
by myself, but as long
as I have that moment that
where I can kind of connect
with that inner self and
just establish some kind
of balance, it could,
you know, 10-15 minutes
before I'm fine.
- I think that you're like
a naturally chill person.
[Seal] I'm not.
- I think people that are ADHD
(Seal laughs)
- [Ava] You sound so chill.
- You sound very chill.
And I'm like, I'm too ADHD.
So that's why I have
to carve out the time.
- I'm not chill.
- Oh, okay. You are pretending
really well right now.
- Yeah, I am.
- I'm like, "What does he do?
Meditate? What should I do?"
- I know, give us some tips.
- I know.
I was like, I could definitely
use some of that help.
But I wanna talk about your new album.
This is the coolest title.
It's Diamonds and Dance Floors.
So like why is that the title?
- Thank you.
So Diamonds and Dance Floors
was the first song on the album.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- One of the first that
I wrote for the album.
And at that time I didn't
have an album title.
And it was called
Diamonds and Dance Floors,
the title track.
And after I finished it, I was like,
"why does this feel so right?"
Especially with like,
starting in the pandemic
I wanted to be on a dance floor.
That song, the title track is talking
about like being in my
kitchen and living room
just dancing by myself wishing
I was feeling the rhythm
and just bodies next to me.
And so...
- (Kelly) Yeah.
- It just came about when I
wrote Diamonds and Dance Floors.
- I heard, so what's the song
Million Dollar Baby about?
- It's about coming out
stronger from a breakup I had.
- I thought, I was like, a lot
of people went through a
breakup during the pandemic.
And it was a hard time already,
I feel like for a lot of us.
But then going through that
and just being feeling more
isolated and more lonely.
I think a lot of creatives
got to work in the studio.
Because that's how we kind
of, that's our outlet, right?
Is that kind of what
this album is for you?
- Oh, for sure.
I would always say I'm never talking
about my personal life.
I'm never gonna do it.
I'm not gonna do it.
I'm only gonna talk about how
I came up in the industry.
I'm gonna talk about female
empowerment and that's it.
And then I died inside. (laughs)
- Yeah.
- And that was all I could write about.
- That was all I could even-
- But unfortunately it's highly relatable-
- [Ava] Yeah.
- Like people that can't write music.
Like maybe that's how they get through.
Even before I started writing,
that's how I could cope.
- Oh yeah.
- That's how I could connect.
- No, I see things differently.
Heartbreak is actually,
yes, it's bad and negative
but it's also a good thing.
And I, because you
change, you grow stronger-
- [Kelly] You learn about yourself.
- you learn about yourself.
You see life differently.
You see people differently.
You appreciate things more.
I don't know, it's, I came
out from the other side
like completely different.
To the point where I'm just like,
"do I get heartbroken again?"
(laughing) Just kidding.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Don't worry, there's therapy for that.
- I don't want to, I really
don't want to. But...
- It is amazing. I always make this joke.
I only make good records
whenever sadness involved.
It's hard to write,
like, it is a lot harder to
write happy songs I feel like.
When you're writing
about desperation or ache
or sadness or just some kind
of like thing to overcome,
it's just more appealing to me.
- It's... (laughing)
- Well...
- It's crazy. It just,
it hits differently,
lyrics to me now.
- [Kelly] Yeah I agree.
- For sure.